[Music]
the council yesterday held its monthly
meeting for october and early on the
agenda was the topic of speed limits in
the Rangi or a wooden road area
following community feedback council
staff are proposing that speed limits be
reduced along sections of regular wooden
road greeson's road boys Road in
Northbrook Road Council has approved
public consultation on the proposed
changes which is due to start on the 8th
of October
the council also adopted the provisional
local alcohol policy 2018 changes from
the previous policy attempt to make
rules around opening hours consistent
between unlicensed and off licensed
premises it also proposes that on
licensed opening hours for the day
preceding a public holiday be treated
the same as weekends the policy will
return to the council for adoption once
the appeal process is completed
finally the council extended the
district road maintenance contract for
one further year the contract is
currently awarded to saikhan they have
performed consistently well and
quarterly performance reviews however
some councillors expressed their desire
to see a higher level of service
overall the district's roading network
has judged as being in good condition
and above average when compared
nationally
the next monthly council meeting will
take place on Tuesday the 6th of
November
[Music]